どっちかです!
最近ものを買いすぎて
どっちが　どっちか　分んないんだよね
多分こっちだと思う
（開封音）
あ!　これだ!
もう片方の段ボールには、何が入っているのだろうか
気になりすぎて寝れない日々が
一週間続いた
はい！ というわけで  今回はこちら!
消える魔球
消える魔球と書いてあるんですが
こちらどんな物かといいますと
ボール型投てき消化用具でございます
火元近くに投げて も～、  なんか  投げるだけ
消火器より簡単    素早く消火   投げやすい   後片付けが楽
というわけで  夏場はよく  火を使う場面  が多いと思います
花火やらバーべキューやら
二つしかねぇわ
いろんなその日常生活で
夏じゃなくてもいいよ、ひとまずその・・・
（咳）
とりあえず火を使うのは危ないんですよ
で、危ないんですけど  なんか 消火器とか 置いてあるんですけども
消火器を使うのって 実際多分 難しいし、
使ったことない方も　多いと思うので、
今回こちらの消える魔球
火事みたいなね、火が起きてる場所に投げると、
それだけで消火ができるというすごい優れものらしいです
それにしても舐めたカラーリングですな
こんな感じで火事が起きてても
ここに向かってポイって投げたらすぐ火が消えるみたいな
すごい!
こちらのおうえぇ～（;´д｀）
今からバーベキューに行くんですけども
なんか！
なんか予想以上に燃える気がするんですよ
予想以上に燃える気がする
普通に僕はバーベキュー楽しみたいんだけども
ひょっとしたら・・・火事が起きるかもしれない
ちょっとこの消える魔球を持ってて
バーベキューしてみようと思います
だってこのカラーリングでそんな効果あるか?
って思っちゃいますよ
僕これほんとまだ信じれないんで
ﾁｮｯﾄ今回は　これの威力というか
ほんとにちゃんと火を消せるのかっていうのを　ちょっと検証していこうと思います
では行こう!
今日はもう俺のおごりで肉食っていいから
ありがとうござい　　任せろ！
では行こう、さっそく
夏っぽいね　　夏っぽいよね
せみがうるせぇ
さっそくバーベキューやっていきましょう
はい！
見えますか?
見えます!
ちゃんと燃えますね
おいおい(;・∀・)
すごい・・・あの・・・炎出るようにしたんで
ここで今日はバーベキューしようと思います
まさき、ちょっと肉持ってきといて
頼む
肉持ってきてる間に俺火、つけとくから
ちなみになんですけど、これ実は環境とかにも優しいらしいので
今回みたいに
いやまだ火事になるとは言ってないぞ
火事になるとは一言も言ってないんですけども
外でやるときも環境にやさしいので大丈夫らしいです
じゃあ、いってら
行ってらっしゃい
さてと
まさきが肉取いってる間に
火でも焚いとくか
楽しみだな～
さ～て まさき来るまで待つか
やばい！
やっ・・・やっ!
はっ、はっ( ´∀｀ )
ねぇ　やばい!　まさき
ちょっと大丈夫?
待て結構やばい!結構やばい!
結構あれだ
ちょっ・・まじなんでトングも燃えんの?
トングは燃えないでしょ
待てやばい！　これは！
火事だ～！！
投げるだけでいいらしい
行くぞ！
♪ チーン／(^o^)＼
ちょっと待って
まじやばい
待て待て。もっと 思いっきりやったほうがいいのかな?
これ効果なくない？
もっう一回行きます
熱っ！
火出てない？
え？まってなんで玉から火出てんの？
待って待ってワァ!!
待って待って、、わぁ
待って待ってワァ！
ア～びっくりした
うぉ！熱っ!
えっ待って
待って
え、待って！リュック!リュック燃えてね!?wwww
リュック燃えてる!
待って待ってまじやばいちょっと待って待って
石の辺とか燃えてるよ？
いやほんとそうなんだよ
消火しないとまじでﾔﾊﾞいよ
これ多分まだ使えるよね？
いける！
消えろ!!
いやマジで、なんで、なんで、なんで？
ちょっと消えないので、　ちょっとラストもう一個あるんですけど
次で確実に消します
消すよ？次消すよ！
ふわって・・・やったほうがいいんじゃない?
上から？
こう？　行きます!
はい！消えました！
じゃ普通に落とすよ!
あ～でもなんか
熱っ、熱っ！